-Guys, it is Tuesday.
It is time for "WeTweet."
Here we go.
-♪ WeTweet ♪
♪ WeTweet ♪
-Now welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we as
a group decide
something that
we should post on Twitter.
I'm going to show you
five different tweets.
We're all going to vote
on whether you like
each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats.
You can vote for all of them.
You can vote for none of them.
Whatever you want to do.
We're going to see
the results live.
We have a graphic
that moves up and down.
Everything that's
high technology.
We spent all of our money
on this technology.
Yeah. Voting technology.
We're the only show...
-In the universe.
-Well.
-In this building.
At this time.
[ Laughter ]
On this day.
-Yes. Thank you.
That is doing this technology.
Higgins, Roots,
you all have clickers.
-Got 'em.
-Whatever tweet will get
the most likes, so we'll tweet
it out live on the show
so that you all can
like it at home and wetweet it.
-Ah!
-It's a shared experience.
Alright.
You guys ready for this?
Here we go.
Our first tweet is...
-Wow!
-It's a thinker there.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-If you want to read
something funny...
-Yeah, you got to go to Twitter.
-You go on Twitter.
-You want to watch something,
you go to TikTok.
-That's correct. Thank you.
-So therefore...
-Yeah. Alright. Good luck here.
I don't know.
I don't know how this one's
going to do,
but let's look at the results.
Come on.
Ooh, God.
[ Sad tuba ]
Overwhelming no. No, thanks.
-No, thank you.
-They prefer not to read.
-How's Hashtag doing?
Is he okay?
♪♪
No, don't play that. No, no.
There you go. Alright.
This next one here says...
[ Laughter ]
One or the other.
-Yeah. Choose.
-One or the other.
They're very dangerous,
those toe rings.
-Yeah.
-Be careful.
Let's see the results
on this toe ring one.
Alright. Not bad.
Alright. Thank you.
Whew. Now I know they work.
Now I know the clickers work.
Alright, good.
Alright. Thank you.
Thank you for being so honest.
Alright, here we go.
This next one here says...
[ Laughter ]
-A cocktail? Yes.
-Why not?
-Alright. I'd love to.
-It's 5:00 somewhere.
Oh, my -- Henry!
[ Laughter ]
-Five of my friends!
-Let's see the results here.
I think this one's...
Oh, yeah! That's good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That one's in the lead.
That's good.
Thank you very much. Not bad.
Let's try this one here.
Next up says...
[ Laughter ]
I like that. It's like...
-I must be a ghost?
-Yeah.
Alright,
let's see the results here.
Alright. Okay.
Hey. Very honest.
Very honest audience.
[ Sad tuba ]
They don't like it.
Thank you, Tuba.
[ Laughter ]
-They're human beings.
-Yeah, they're human beings.
Here we go.
Our last one here says...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-A lot of scotch drinkers.
-I think it was the delivery
on that that really helped.
[ Southern accent ] What the
hell flavor is butterscotch?!
-You might be a redneck.
-It ain't butter.
It ain't scotch.
What the hell flavor is
butterscotch?
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] Let's see.
I have a good feeling, though.
-I do, too. I think this is
going to be number one.
-It's going to be
this one, right?
Wait, what was the other one
that was close?
[ Audience yelling "shrimp" ]
-Shrimp was 149.
-Oh, I like shrimp better,
I think.
I almost don't want to see
the results.
-Well, you sold this one
so hard.
-I did. What the hell flavor is
butterscotch?
Let's see the results
on butterscotch.
Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow!
-Whoa!
-That's not bad!
I like butterscotch!
-Oh, my God!
Thank you very much.
There you go right there.
Thank you very much, everybody.
I'm going to pose this
during the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like,
give it a wetweet and enjoy.